It wasn't so bad that the program crashed in this case. I can just add the
condition back, compile, and run again. And this only cost me a couple of
minutes. But if I had been running this program for a whole day or something,
and it had crashed and lost all my data. Or my website went down and I had to
rush to my computer and run the program again to get it up and running. I would
be pretty sad. If you find yourself casting something to an interface type and
checking whether things are instances of other things. It's often a sign that
you could design your code better, so that you could make the Java compiler do
more work for you, and find errors at compile time instead of run time. So,
what could we have done in this case? Maybe what we really wanted instead of a
Moveable and a Drawable interface was some other interface, like Animated.
Maybe Animated would have void draw As well as void move. And when houses
implemented the move method, they could return immediately instead of actually
moving. That way we could ask all of the animated elements to move And not
worry about run-time errors. Or maybe we should accept that one ArrayList isn't
enough here. Maybe we wanted two ArrayLists one Drawable and one Movable. There
are lots of possibilities here, finding the best ones is something that you'll
find by trying more things, keep practicing.